[Musique]
chaque samedi soir et ligue naulleau et
ses chroniqueurs se réunissent sur ces
huit dents de quoi je me mêle
en deuxième partie de soirée pour
commenter à leur manière l'actualité en
plateau le docteur frédéric saldmann
qu'on a entre autres pu voir dans tpm
paix mais aussi dans objectif 10 ans -
sur m6 s'est chargé d'un rôle
pédagogique pour conseiller les
téléspectateurs et leur indiquer comment
rester en bonne santé
mais voilà ses conseils n'ont pas plu à
certains internautes qui dénoncent là
des propos sexistes et c'est un conseil
en particulier qui a surpris et choqué
certains internautes
un conseil qui s'est affiché à l'écran
dans le tableau rédigé par le
professionnel de santé les femmes
doivent éviter de pleurer sinon cela
altère la libido des hommes
sacré chez l'homme une chute de la vidéo
rapportant immédiatement sur les réseaux
sociaux les internautes ont réagi à
lebon sexisme comme on les aime
j'imagine que c'est juste préciser pour
les femmes parce qu'on est des
chouineuse et que les vrais hommes ne
pleurent pas je vais faire plein de
choses pour rester en bonne santé
à commencer par tu as écouté ce mec
alors selon vous ces propos sont-ils
sexiste ce soir le docteur frédéric
saldmann était avec nous pour
s'expliquer sur ses propos
c'est vrai que ça fait alors ça ne
polémiquent cette affaire chez eric
naulleau et vous receviez donc frédéric
saldmann qui est avec nous merci d'être
avec nous pour la promotion de votre
livre on n'est jamais mieux soigner que
par soi même et vous avez dit donc je
vous le répète au cours de l'émission
les femmes doivent éviter de pleurer
sinon cela altère la libido des hommes
alors vous allez me dire ce qu'on en
pense et après bien sûr on dort à la vie
de monsieur sun man notre docteur on
mais on verra ça après les chéris merci
que je suivais un petit peu l'émission
et valérie benaïm les bras m'en tombent
parfois vous entendre les bras les bras
en temps non mais pardon docteur
saldmann mais quand on entend ça
évidemment le premier truc qu'on se dit
c'est donc pour satisfaire la libido de
ces messieurs de la falloir que moi si
j'ai un coup dur si je me sens pas bien
je rêverais de mes larmes et que je me
mette dans un coin qui me disent non
quand même si je pleure ce pauvre petit
monsieur avec qui je vis va avoir une
libido en berne donc il va falloir que
je prenne sur moi c'est vrai que quand
on le prend comme ça pardon mais on se
dit mais dans quel monde on est on est
en 2021
alors s'il va vous répondre je dis rien
eric juste quelque chose qui est un peu
compliqué le débat c'est qui est une
excellente question de l'actrice pascale
arbillot qui étaient aussi invités qui
dit est ce que c'est vrai linverse est
ce que les larmes des hommes font
baisser la libido des femmes et vous
avez répondu non il n'ya pas d'étude
donc en fait les études sont un peu
orienté et elle-même sexy fiscaux mon on
étudie qu'une partie du problème là moi
je trouve ça très surprenant gilles moi
j'ai hâte d'entendre les explications du
docteur parce que c'est vrai que ça m'a
choqué quand une femme pleure le seul la
seule chose à faire c'est de la
réconforter de faire qu elle ne pleure
plus ils sont bien m qui voulez quoi
vous faites quoi
mais je la prends dans mes bras je lui
parle j'essaie de m'y rendre j'ai pas
envie d'exercer ma libido quand je vois
une femme pleurer alors démarré voilà
donc c'est la satisfaction de la libido
d'un homme ça passe mille fois après le
fait de consoler une femme qui pleure
donc sonné pays études j'ai pas compris
vos propos j'ai été choqué géraldine
alors moi franchement docteur j'en ai
marre j'en ai marre parce qu'en fait je
trouve que vous êtes une sorte de gourou
avec des punchline
et vous faites une sorte de médecine de
comptoir qui moi me dérange parce que
j'ai l'impression que vous arrivez sur
les plateaux tout le temps avec des
petites phrases un peu tout fait
il faut se laver les mains alors la
raison aurait il faut ranger wayne on
met d'accord mais enfin on n'a pas
attendu un docteur seul mannequin grands
docteurs pour dire des lieux comme il
faut on a tendance à l'oublier prof
bahamas et moi franchement voilà la fois
que j'oublie de me laver les mains alors
on recommence toujours il commence
toujours par l'histoire de la nu soul à
paris un grand truc comme ça mais vous
l'avez l'anus il apprend double il est
bientôt là bas et qu'après on n'a pas la
russe donc pas ça ça m'énerve un peu et
je trouve que quelques quelque part en
ces moments un peu compliqué où les gens
sont un peu angoissés ça décrédibilise
la médecine et donc s'améliorer
l'anc est bien sûr des propos ils
peuvent pas être sexy ce mail enquête
enquête c'est si tu pleures tu fais pas
l'amour c'est sale enquête sa carrière a
dit moi quand je pleure ou si ma
compagne est plein on va pas faire
l'amour si on s'engueule il peut y avoir
de réconciliation sur le royer en cas d'
angola d' mais quand tu pleures tu fais
pas l'amour quand tu pleures bon que
l'enquêté allait elle est bien mais ça
dépend si tu as des oignons le problème
c'est ce qu'a dit eric le problème c'est
qu'elle n'a pas été fait pour les hommes
aussi c'est là que ça devient ses mains
eh ben ils ont pas fait aucune enquête
pour les impôts ça me paraît logique que
quand tu pleures ta libido et baisse les
dents michelle wie page est quand même
le spécialiste au liban
d'où est-ce que tu pleures tu fais
l'amour mais lui ai fait la bourde amand
de coly
non mais j'aimerais bien savoir
l'explication je vous écris de choquer
partie de l'explication scientifique ne
me convainc pas mais c'est une vraie
explication je ferais tout mon temps
logique bon je l'avais en face à la
nature elles auront déjà la question est
un peu déçu et sociologique est un peu
idiotes on se demande pourquoi et c'est
vrai que c'est un petit peu décevant
qu'elles soient relayées par un médecin
et donc par une personne qui exerce la
science et qui effectivement on va faire
un petit buzz sur un plateau de télé à
propos d'une étude sociologique qui est
complètement idiot isabelle est vrai que
c'est un petit peu agacé alors dit que
si c'est vrai chaque fois que j'ai pas
envie je vais m'en servir un à l'air
super mais je savais qu'il fallait pas
que je donne la parole frédéric saldmann
sais que je suis très fan de vous moi on
n'est jamais mieux soigner la semaine
pour ça que j'invite tout le temps dans
l'émission est là est-ce que vous
comprenez cette folie alors c'est très
simple il suffit de lire le livre
voilà le chapitre concernés c'est très
simple c'est exactement l'inversé
d'accord en fait l'étude a été faite
pour étudier les signaux chimiques qui
se font lorsqu'une femme pleure et de
comprendre que le fait que ça et un la
libido masculine prouve que en fait les
données ne se font pas se faire au
niveau de la sexualité de la séduction
mais de l' écoute certains hommes quand
il voit une femme qui pleure se met à
penser que je vais la console et d'une
certaine tension comme gilles oui c'est
la réaction que j'ai entendu non il faut
écouter la dépression chez la femme et
deux fois plus fréquente que chez
l'homme même par rapport à raymond est
souvent une mauvaise interprétation des
larmes qui va conduire à une nonne
écoute de la femme est justement ce que
j'ai l'étude c'est ce qui m'a intéressé
c'est pour ça que j'en ai parlé à l'été
la cheville a fait au niveau
scientifique
je regrette qu'elle n'ait pas été fait
chez les hommes et moi et on a trouvé
les mêmes choses là c'est que ce n'est
pas sur le terrain de la sexualité que
va se faire les choses ni de la
séduction c'est d'écouter avec des cats
s les raisons profondes de la tristesse
parce que s'il n'y a pas ce dialogue
dans un couple et bien c'est l'ouverture
mais la dépression vous savez dans le
mot maladie il y as mal à dire non et
dans ce cas là le langage du corps c'est
à la maladie
c'est à dire c'est comme jacques a dit
même maladie c est ce qu il existe la
même étude sur les eaux basque un homme
qui pleure ça altère la libido de la
femme deux minutes évidemment non mais
c'est pour vous c'est un nouveau docteur
moi je pense lui l'a pas fait l'étude
qui a été fait était pour qu'une
meilleure écoute justement de la femme
et je pense que chez l'homme c'est
exactement pareil
les larmes une étude font du bien ça
fait du bien de pleurer ça permet de
réguler l'humeur c'est une chose et il
faut pas se retenir de pleurer
est-ce que ça fait du mal faux pas mais
laury comme ça c'est un signal
on envoie vers l'autre que ce soit
l'homme vers la femme la femme vers
l'homme et qui signifie que c'est pas
sur le terrain de la libido que ça va se
passer mais d'une vraie écoute et c'est
pour ça ira l'émotion l'émotion
exactement et justement en citant cette
étude je voulais exprimer le fait il
faut écouter avec délicatesse les femmes
et surtout pas voir des comportements
types harcèlement ou lorsqu'il ya ça
c'est l'inversé bien sûr oui j'en ai à
peu pris les pieds dans le tapis quand
même parce que là vous dites faut pas
empêcher des femmes de pleurer ou les
hommes de pleurer et la phrase que vous
citez ces 10e
vous dites aux femmes éviter de pleurer
dans le lit mais mes propos traverse
donc ça a été mal fait dans lesquelles
est là si je peux me permettre c'est que
vous nous expliquer le pourquoi du
comment mais c'est pas ça la question là
on parle de polémique donc au final
quand vous mettez une phrase comme ça
vous savez très bien qu'elle va faire
polémique parce que ce sera êtes choc
donc c'est pas le fait que vous nous
expliquer pourquoi vous avez de sa hampe
la première parce que vous avez dit dans
votre discours c il faut lire mon livre
pour comprendre la phrase bah oui il est
là le problème est là on choque pas
léger mais vous lire des livres n'est
pas venu aider pas venu ici combien de
fois les noms connus est assis on
l'accuserait oui mais oui mais c'est une
polémique qui est sorti parce que elle
était sortie c'est normal sachant
gambade il ya plein de phrases qui sont
sortis de leur contexte
sur les réseaux sociaux et forcément
quand on lit la phrase sortie de sacs ou
de son contexte forcément la comprend
pas elle peut tout comprendre
ouais bah oui enfin oui mais non c'est
pour que les gens comprennent pas du
tout
à lui tout seul il faut dire tout
libanais c'est donc elle est extraite
j'exprime exactement le contraire c'est
que c'est un signal qui vont respecter
lorsqu'une femme pleure et un homme
aussi qui pleure à ce truc tout
simplement ces signaux que ce n'est pas
sur la libido que ça va se passer
et si on comprend beaucoup de couple par
exemple n'écoute pas tiens les pupilles
si elles sont dilatées ou contractés en
épée chaoui excès des signaux qui prouve
que la personne n'est pas en condition
il faut regarder les pépites voir entrer
chez 5 août et d'avoir tué est ce que
c'est un coup dur et donc d'être bien on
a on a des petits conseils qu'est ce que
vous nous avez montré la chaleur parce
que j'ai voilà alors à faire ça c'est
quoi c'est pour être en bonne santé il
faut manger du climat du cumin et du thé
vert des brocolis et des épinards c'est
à dire je ne tente même pas mal
séquentielle pratiquer minimum 30
minutes d'exercices quand une balle si
ce qu'il ya dans votre livre à pourrir
là pour pourrez vous pour être en bonne
santé il faut éviter le désordre dans la
maison
oui parce qu'on a observé c'est une
étude qui a montré que quand la cuisine
par exemple et désordonnée ouais j'en
mange plus tous à placer sa voix là les
femmes doivent éviter de pleurer si vous
avez écrit dans le livre là ne pas boire
plus de trois tasses de café par jour
merde là sinon sexy trop un forcément
oui parce que le trot et les menées de
mieux mais bien sûr je connais moi
j'étais hyper pote avec el gringo ne pas
regarder de vieux films écouter de
vieilles chansons passerini regarde
colombo toutes les seins parce que quand
on regarde des vieux films on veut un
acteur très jeune ouais ensuite relevé
aujourd'hui très vieux l'impression que
le temps s'accélère way a tu prend dans
la gueule way ne pas exposer des photos
de proches ayant plus de 5
en fait c'est pareil ne pas se comparer
aux autres
oui parce que on ne sera jamais heureux
mais serait battu à ses oreilles vous le
dis arrêtez de vous comparer et ne pas
dormir tard pour éviter la dépression
ça c'est important mais tout fut donc ce
qu'est leur toit